you know I think it's fair to say that
the Conservative Party is facing a
challenging few months struggling to
keep hold of some brexit supporters and
trying to pull some of those young
voters away from Jeremy Corbyn so this
week I think two Loughborough to speak
to local MP Nicky Morgan and see what
the voters and one of the great
political bellwethers make of tourism a
prime ministerial office is a heavy
burden to bear whilst there's no
shortage of people ready to advise to
ease away from big business - Boris
Johnson it can sometimes be difficult to
tell whether they actually want to help
or are in fact on the warpath much has
been written about the wisdom of markets
but what of market times you know the
constituency of Loughborough is
considered something of a political
bellwether it's reflected the national
result of every general election since
1974 a perceptive bunch of waters and
deeds all of which makes their views on
brexit and the woman responsible for
delivering it rather interesting I'm
happier you with the way things are
going awful terrible
I think we made a terrible mistake and I
think we're paying for it now and we'll
pay for it a far more before we get out
a conservative voter so question has to
come I mean what do you make of Tereza
may that election result and actually
how she's performed since she's been in
Downing Street I think she's a weakest
leader we've had in many many years and
unfortunately I think a lot of the old
MPs would be pleased to get rid of her
but there's no candidate out there that
you would say it's outstanding and would
reap later the actual leave in Europe I
think is a very good idea I mean I
wouldn't run my own house like they
would you know them get expect other
people just tell you what's doing your
own house you know to me personally I
think that's wrong we should be able to
say what we want in this country for the
best of our people what do you make of
fear of the Conservative government and
one in particular so these are main not
very good true five things which is
fairly weak to tell you the truth what
do you make of brexit and the way it's
been handled at the moment well we voted
for breakfast
and we're very disappointed at all the
shilly-shallying and the Havering about
we see myself if we do succeed in coming
out and then it'll be in our life will
be it'll be any different they're
talking about staying in the single
market with their talk about a big
divorce bill waste of time
so in your mind then is it is it is it
just not the brexit that was that was
chronic or dia still you can always rely
on the young to be full of optimism and
positivity I find that a lot of
conservative views a lot of conservative
party members people seems look down on
the young people they seem say oh you
only like lady because they're offering
you unrealistic free promises stuff and
I feel this sort of dismissal of our
views this myths of our voice makes all
people feel really disenfranchised
against the Conservatives we just don't
really feel they care about us
the Conservatives just seemed to drone
on about Briggs at one time and when
they release their manifesto they mopped
it up and then you had labor you know
Gemma cotton going out and meeting all
these people and stuff and you know it
just seemed a lot more free-flowing and
natural recording rather than the
robotic Drita made the deal hasn't even
struck yet and people are still
complaining about our breakfast ability
the prices inflation it's doing this you
know there's uncertainty over jobs I
just feel that concept it's not
confident if they do you attract it
would be difficult to track me from
labor to be honest then I would honor
who I'm voting for it will be difficult
to be honest with the average age of a
Conservative Party member rising to 72
and plenty of youthful opposition to
brexit our concerns really being heard